michael grady yes network
it's unfortunate that this season even
has to be asked but um someone tried to
toss a water bottle at
kyrie or did toss a water bottle at
kyrie um as you guys were walking off
the floor
just your your thoughts on just again um
uh an unfortunate act and the fan was
arrested but just
what can be done about you know again
protecting protected players in
situations like this
i mean fans got to grow up at some point
i know
that being in the house for a year and a
half with the pandemic
um got a lot of people on edge got a lot
of people who are stressed out
um but when you come to these games you
gotta realize man these these these men
are human
you know we're not animals we're not in
a circus uh
you coming to the game it's not all
about you as a fan so have some respect
for the game have some respect for these
human beings
and have some respect for yourself your
mother wouldn't be proud of you throwing
water bottles at
basketball players or spitting on
players or tossing popcorn so
go to [ __ ] up uh and enjoy the game you
know it's bigger
it's bigger than you